[Music]
will Bitcoin be worth a million dollars
by mid-june Balaji srinivasan made a
public bet that it would against a
pseudonymous Twitter user called James
Medlock who identifies as a tax
Enthusiast and hyperinflation doubter
I'll let srinivasana explain in this
clip from our recent live stream the
point was to bring attention to the
stealth financial crisis that uh at the
time that I tweeted this that had not
been acknowledged as such
so we're in like and we're all in a base
of high Invasion and unlike 2008 the US
dollar is no longer too big to fail
Economist and monetarian banking expert
Lawrence H white doubts that Bitcoin
will replace the dollar but he does
think that the banking system is much
shakier than public officials like Fed
chair Jerome Powell are letting on
our ranking system is sound and
resilient with strong capital and
liquidity
we will continue to closely monitor
conditions in the banking system and are
prepared to use all of our tools as
needed to keep it safe and sound no I
think I'm on biology side when it comes
to the soundness of the banking system
or lack of soundness of the U.S banking
system and I think he's doing a real
service by drawing attention to what's
been going on white says that because
the FED kept interest rates low and
injected cash into the banks even after
the nation came out of pandemic lockdown
we got hammered by inflation so the
Central Bank quickly hiked rates in
response leaving America's Banks holding
a lot of government bonds that were
suddenly worth less than they paid for
them a lot less see those bars those are
the losses FDIC insured Banks would
experience if they were forced to sell
when they did stress tests last year
of the largest banks
they simulated what would happen to
their net worth if interest rates Rose
from zero to two percent
and that's as high as they went
and at two percent SBB would have been
okay
if they had you know tested for three
percent four percent where are we now
four and three quarter percent interest
rates they would have seen a lot more
trouble Than The Regulators wanted to
see so there has been a failure to
look deeply enough and now to stop more
Bank runs like the one that brought down
Silicon Valley Bank the FED created a
new program to guarantee Banks more cash
to meet their obligations JPMorgan
analysts estimate it could inject up to
two trillion dollars though it could
also be a mere 460 billion according to
more conservative estimates and so the
bitcoinization thesis or the hype of
inquisitions is that as the U.S economy
just gets worse and worse and more
unpredictable people seek a safe haven
not in Money Market funds and big Banks
which are in my view a trap in this
cycle in a way that they were not in
2008. I agree that Bitcoin is a vital
check on a government's power to
endlessly devalue its currency as well
as against a total surveillance state
I don't know if Serena Boston's hyper
bitcoinization thesis is right what I do
know is this isn't sustainable
those red and green lines are the
inflation and interest rates the
interest rate is supposed to drive down
the inflation rate but the big problem
is that blue line on top that is our
31.4 trillion dollar problem the
national debt it's reached terrifying
levels having surpassed annual gross
domestic product with no end in sight
and one thing you don't want when you
have a lot of debt are really high
interest rates investment analyst Lynn
Alden explained the conundrum in another
recent conversation the occurred
environment we find ourselves in the
2020s in many ways is more similar to
the 1940s which is the vast majority of
the money creation and the inflation was
not because of excessive Bank lending I
mean Bank lending levels are pretty
normal and almost all of it was from
unusually large physical deficits that
we've not seen since World War II as a
percentage of GDP because you had over
100 debt the GPA it was very hard to
raise rates and so instead they just
kept rates low despite High inflation
and anyone holding dollars bonds and
things like that really got devalued on
an ongoing basis and so I think that
unfortunately 2020s are kind of shaping
up in that direction the FED can
continue to hike interest rates and
create more money to keep the bank
solvent
that's not a long-term solution the debt
will eventually crush the economy
srinivasan thinks Bitcoin is the way out
white thinks it's a return to
gold-backed money both agree that the
government's unrestrained money creation
left America and the world in a
precarious position it's really just
like the failure of central planning you
know just in a totally different way
than communism or whatever it's just
another just Central planning complete
face plant where they all make the same
mistake at the same time because all the
you know Innovation or contrariness or
whatever is being leached out of the
system and srinivasan worries that this
Central planning will only get worse as
the government moves further to quash
the threat by instituting a central bank
digital currency and so every dollar can
be tracked in the ecosystem it's more
programmable it's like it was like a
suite you know where it's got a a hook
in the bait and the the hook is total
surveillance total control
um ability to freeze account drain
accounts so will Balaji win his million
dollar Bitcoin bet
I'm not so sure about that 90-day
timeline and after talking to him I
don't think he is either do you actually
believe bitcoin's going to a million
dollars or is it really just to draw is
it like a you know drawing attention to
this problem that you've laid out I
think Bitcoin will eventually go to a
million dollars but I do think he's
raised an important question for us all
to ponder what do you do when you can't
trust your government to keep your
hard-earned money sound secure and at
least somewhat private
part of that answer is you take steps to
do it yourself that might mean hedging
with Bitcoin or gold or your investment
of choice it might mean keeping your
data and communication safe by opting
into privacy-centric tools
I think we're headed into a more
decentralized and individualized World
whether politicians and Central Bankers
like it or not Bitcoin is a very
powerful tool to protect against abuses
of both the dollar and the Renminbi
um for essentially American dissidents
in Chinese distance if you want to put
it that way it can't be inflated it
can't be seized
um you can also by the way use the
private keys with something like Noster
to get you free speech right at the end
of the Soviet Union
um you know the blue jeans were the
symbol of like freedom and prosperity
that's what Bitcoin is it's a global
symbol of freedom and prosperity you're
a free person if you can have Bitcoin
and you can move it around hey if you'd
like to watch my full conversation with
Balaji srinivasan and Lawrence H white
you can click right here or if you want
to watch another clip from that
conversation you can click right here